it is now my great pleasure to introduce
our next speakers
both of whom have been strong advocates
for Democratic cooperation under the
agreement
Ursula vanderlein the president of the
European commission is the first woman
to hold that position and she has spent
her career advocating for women's rights
public health peace and so much more
Charles Michelle president of the
European Council has shepherded the EU
through Regional conflicts a global
pandemic and a very rapidly changing
geopolitical landscape
it is now my pleasure to invite
president Michelle to the stage
[Applause]
dear secretary Clinton
dear prime minister sunach the t-shirts
Excellency ladies and gentlemen
brother Roger of disease
a Christian leader who devoted his life
to reconciling different Christian
denominations one said
strength and courage
is when someone can shake hands and
listen to the other despite past
divisions
it was precisely this strength and
courage 25 years ago that led to the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
a remarkable and where achievement that
largely ended three decades of fighting
in Northern Ireland
especially where when we look at the Arc
of human history
full of unself conflicts they continue
to divide peoples leading to entrenched
suffering generation after generation
yet right here in Northern Ireland
Against All Odds a peace deal was
switched and A New Hope to truth that
day it was not the end of Journey but it
was a new beginning ending on John Fleet
and securing the wise of all people in
Northern Ireland
and that's why we come together today to
mark this anniversary
of this history deal
it's our duty to keep the spirit of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement to life
just as it was born 25 years ago
we pay tribute first and foremost
to the people of this land
the countless unsung heroes yes I told
them Heroes The Visionaries who imagine
the society reconciled with the past and
able to look to the Future
a future forced in peace free from
violence all the people of this land
willing to embark on a journey towards
reconciliation
the politicians the treaties the
agreements they are all crucial to the
process
but it's the will of the people the will
of the people there's the Steely
backbone the vision for what Northern
Ireland can be
thousands of unnamed people over many
years worked to unlock this agreement
in politics public Life religion Civil
Society
the full story of this peace agreement
cannot be told without acknowledging
their Brave contributions
we felt the will of the people The Good
Friday agreement would be just another
paper in the museum of failed peace
deals and I'd like to pay a particular
tribute to the women of Northern Ireland
like Betty Williams and Maritime Jaya
and of course we can never forget the
enormous contributions of the Visionary
leaders leaders like John Hume David
Trimble Bertie Ahern Tony Blair Bill
Clinton George Mitchell and so many
others their efforts your efforts in
short that the people's will did not
fall on Barren ground
so today
we must protect the genes of
disagreement and stay true to its
principles of Peace respect tolerance
because this is the best way to knit
together a society that's stronger and
more united on a land that share
together
ladies and gentlemen
dear friends
in the European Union we also know the
importance of the strong backing of our
citizens
without the support of the citizens our
Union would not have seen the light of
day
enemies who once fought each other on
European Soul agreed and decided to
create shared institutions on that very
same cell
to work together to build trust and
mutual understanding on a path towards
reconciliation
when the UK and Ireland joined the EU
together in 1973 they subscribed to this
German vision
and over the decades the contacts
between British Irish and EU officials
at all levels helped to cement Mutual
trust and understanding
European projects
one could say help to prepare the ground
for the seed of peace to take root in
Northern Ireland it focused on improving
the daily lives of people on building
alliances not on identity and politics
it focused on practical issues like
agriculture transport economic
cooperation but also rule of flow and
citizens rights our goal was to Foster
our diverse identities while still
uniting I want these differences and to
build a strong single Market not to
erase borders but to make them less
divisive
less important less burden some
we also know
that transform into Vision into reality
doesn't happen overnight it requires a
lot of hard work
reconciliation
trust and cooperation are not the work
of ours and this but month years and
decades and it takes willingness to
compromise to step across device and to
take risks
in Europe we do not pretend to have all
the answers but we strive to provide a
space to come together and to work
together on a common vision for our
common destiny
in this Same Spirit the EU was strict to
respond after the first ceasefires in
Northern Ireland in 1994. the European
commission president dollar simply asked
what can you do to help build lasting
peace and this led to the creation of
the eup's programs which have helped to
Foster peace and Reconciliation between
communities since 1995.
the EU has also contributed to a range
of infrastructure projects like for
instance developing the successful
Waterfront area here in Belfast and many
social projects including those aimed at
victims of the troubles on both sides of
the Irish Border
ladies and gentlemen
in the EU we remain fully committed to
Foster in peace and Reconciliation in
Northern Ireland
it's no secret that the United Kingdom's
Sovereign decision to leave the EU post
serious new challenges for instance the
complexities at the border
for the EU our main role has always been
to make sure that brexit does not
undermine the Belfast would try the
agreement and it does not resurrect the
borders and the divisions of the past
and that's why we have always worked to
build trust to find Collective and at
times imaginative Solutions and to move
forward in a way that listens to and
respects the communities in Northern
Ireland
they recently agreed Visa framework does
precisely that it provides a good
opportunity to build a more positive and
stable relationship between the EU and
the UK to work better together to build
trust together and Church in our shared
interest and our common fundamental
values
I think it will provide greater
certainty and with the ability for the
people and businesses in Northern
Ireland
it is you you the people of this fine
lens that must decide your future
together this is the only way to build a
stable and prosperous future
ladies and gentlemen
your country has changed beyond
recognition over the last quarter of a
century
today you have peace in Northern Ireland
and you have something more something
that can only be achieved through peace
you have greater prosperity and for this
reason it has become a model for solving
other entrenched conflicts across the
world some of them in Europe
the Belfast agreement also represents
the product and the high point of
another era an error when the values of
liberal democracies were preeminent in
the world
in the past 25 years
the world has changed dramatically
the September 11th attacks the wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan
the global economy crisis the climate
emergency
covid-19 and now Russia's war against
Ukraine where we see the tragic
consequences of War
in these turbulent times two great
allies like the United Kingdom and the
European union we need each other more
than ever we stand to that together we
stand together to tackle common
challenges like climate change We Stand
Together to uphold human dignity and
human rights in this increasingly
dangerous World Northern Ireland and the
Belfast Good Friday agreement are a
powerful symbol of what our shared
values can achieve
let's continue to build on this
Unstoppable belief in the potential of
peace
for more freedom more Prosperity more
democracy for the people of Northern
Ireland and for all people across the
world I thank you
please welcome to the stage president of
the European commission Ursula
Wonderland
[Applause]
prime minister
t-shock
Chancellor Clinton
president Michelle
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
dear friends
allow me first of all to thank Queen's
University of Belfast and youth
secretary Clinton for this incredible
event
it is an opportunity to thank
and praise the architects of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
but also to look at our
friendship between the United Kingdom
and the European Union and most
importantly
to look at the future of Peace in
Northern Ireland
allow me to begin with a personal memory
in my twenties I studied in London
I fell in love with this vibrant and
vital City colorful and cosmopolitan
it wasn't the late 1970s
and a few years earlier the women's
peace movement in Northern Ireland had
won the Nobel Peace Prize
but the Hope inspired by that
recognition
had largely ebbed away
so during my time in London
when I heard about Northern Ireland in
the news
it was a story of conflict
of bombs and violence in the streets
today my children are in their twenties
and they have learned a completely
different story
a story of reconciliation at Hope
a story of economic and social progress
for young Europeans
Northern Ireland is today a cool place
it's a place of Music film sets and
stunning landscapes
this brighter reality is only possible
because I'm Good Friday
25 years ago
the leaders and the people of Northern
Ireland
decided to plant a seed
in soil previously stained with Blood
and Tears
and it is the seed of peace and
possibility for new generations
which has been growing defiantly ever
since
today we pay tribute to all those who
planted that seed
we thank the Visionary leaders of all
communities
in Northern Ireland
the United Kingdom and Ireland
who believed that
while history shapes people
can also shape history
and this is what happened ever since
the people of Northern Ireland have
shaped a new history
of course Decades of troubles are
impossible to forget
the past cannot be re-written
but writing a new present and future
is always a possibility
and that is exactly what the people of
Northern Ireland have decided to focus
on
being the master of your destiny
it is in this mindset
that my first meeting with prime
minister sunak took place
it was at the United Nations climate
conference in Egypt at the end of last
year
and since that first meeting
we agreed to focus on the road ahead
more than on past disagreements
because the challenges ahead of us are
daunting
for the first time in decades
large-scale war is back in Europe
the foundations of peaceful coexistence
in our continent have come under attack
and This concerns all Europeans not only
Russia
and territorial integrity
foreign
we both want Russia's aggression to fail
and we both want to restore a just peace
in Europe
we still see the world with the same
eyes
we still share the same values and sense
of purpose
we still believe that peace is precious
and can never be taken for granted
and I'm particularly grateful to our
British friends
not only for their unwavering support
for Ukraine and European security
but also for the determination
on that occasion and ever since
to overcome our differences and find
workable solutions to the challenges
that arose after brexit
The Winds of framework is a new
beginning for Old Friends
it turns the page
on years of division and dispute
it is an opportunity to set our sights
on the future of our partnership
and to focus on what brings us together
as President Biden said last week
the dividends of Peace are all around us
Northern Ireland's GDP has more than
doubled since 1998.
and could increase by a further 50
percent
over the next decade
new private Investments
are driving activities like fintech and
cyber security
and more investors are now eyeing at
Northern Ireland this is a unique
opportunity for Northern Ireland
there is so much we can do together
with wisdom and vision
the same wisdom and vision that the
leaders of Northern Ireland have already
shown over the past 25 years
there are so many that deserve special
recognition
like John Hume
and David tremble
who were key
to reaching an agreement
allow me to refer to one
example to someone who 25 years ago did
not agree with the text of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
I'm talking about the Reverend Ian
Paisley
yet
less than 10 years after that Good
Friday
Ian Paisley became Northern Ireland's
first minister
working under the Saint Andrews power
sharing structures
and working with a deputy first Minister
Martin McGinnis
who used to be one of his staunchest
foes
this is one of the Miracles
of the Good Friday Belfast agreement
and the journey of Ian Paisley mirrors
the Journey of thousands of people on
this island
history now calls on today's leaders to
embark on a similar path
and to shape together the future of
Northern Ireland
ladies and gentlemen the future of
Northern Ireland belongs to its people
only you
can make the seed of the Good Friday
Belfast agreement
continue to grow
and to flourish
only you
can take the next step
on the path of prosperity
and possibility
and let me borrow the words of a woman
from Northern Ireland
called Anne Patterson
she gave birth to a baby girl just
minutes after the Good Friday Belfast
agreement was signed
and with her husband she decided to call
the baby hope
and today she says and I quote
peace is a process not an event
everybody is responsible
and change begins with yourself
end of quote
she is so right
I can reassure you
that we the European Union
we'll continue to do our part
and to accompany you on the path of
peace and prosperity
today
my grandchildren
are toddlers
what Northern Ireland
and the whole island of Ireland will
look like
when they are in their twenties
depends on all of us
but the ultimate Choice lies with you
the people of Northern Ireland
to shape your history
and that of the Next Generation
the gateway to a bright future is open
all you need to do is walk through it
thank you very much
thank you
please welcome to the stage the 42nd
President of the United States William
Jefferson Clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you very much I
I have been here so long
that I am reliably informed
that I will owe taxes
if I'm not gone in 48 hours
prime minister tishook
foreign
I got to hear president vonder Layton
all distinguished guests and uh
thank you Berta Hearn for sitting
through one more talk of mine
and
to all of you I
have loved this
I've watched a lot of your panels
at these last two day meetings
on live stream
and then
I've had unique access
to your Chancellor to get a daily report
on what happened
I thank her and
Vice Chancellor Greer and all the people
here at Queens for making us also
welcome
in many ways
the students I've seen here
and the faculty are a metaphor
for the future we hope to see in
Northern Ireland
with people of all backgrounds from all
around the world living and working
together
I must say
I heard the panel in which the
representative from the alliance party
got off I thought the best one-liner I'd
heard about the purpose of government
they do after all hire us to do jobs
so I would ask you to indulge my
attempt to downgrade the rhetoric and
upgrade the reason
I was in Derry yesterday with
Mark Durkin and others and I'm
emotionally spent
but
to me
all of this
comes down to a pretty simple question
what is the meaning of this peace
agreement
lasting for 25 years
and what should happen in the next 25
years
I can tell you it's
a different place than it was in 1995
when I first came here but
then it was a big deal that uh
Jerry Adams and I took shook hands on
the street I mean you would have thought
the pavement was about to crack open
now people would say
what's the matter of those two snobs
they're not even shaking hands on the
street
that's a good thing
but
it's less than 25 years
most peace agreements
fall apart in less than a decade
that's worth remembering
so first why did it last it lasted I
think
because the people demanded it it lasted
because
the process was really good and
Senator Mitchell did a brilliant job of
leading it and negotiating it
and the parties
knew what they really needed
which was knowing that they all would
have a voice in the future
of Northern Ireland and it mandated
cooperation
it forced it in a way that few
agreements do
there would be
renouncing violence
shared decision making shared economic
benefits
prime minister Hearn gave up
the Irish constitutional claim to the
counties of the North
and in return the agreement said
that this area would have special
relationships with the Irish Republic
while
maintaining its
presence in the United Kingdom
and it worked
except when it didn't when the
government went down
but that was a perfectly predictable
result
because whenever you make a big deal
like this
and people have to compromise
and everybody wants to compromise then
they wake up the next day and a certain
number of people who almost always vote
in elections have buyer's remorse and
they say oh my God what did I disagree
to
so that helps
people who are perceived to be stronger
and will bargain harder
and it makes the governments more
vulnerable
so we went through periods that the
government's going down and up and down
and up
but now
the government say I'm down a long time
and
a lot of efforts have been made to get
it back up and this Windsor agreement
seems to me anyway as an outsider who
cares very much
it's about the best deal you could get
to split the baby
to allow the benefits
of
access to the European markets and the
necessity of access
to the UK Market to be reconciled in a
way that will permit
The Best of Both Worlds something that
as far as I can tell nobody else with
this kind of access to the EU has in
their domestic Market
I don't think there's anything quite
like this
so do I hope it will be enough or that
it can be tweaked a little bit I
certainly do
because
no matter how good any deal is
how much endurance there is what really
matters is
how long it has a hold of people's
imagination
and trust and whether the people who are
in positions of power and influence
will always do what's best
for the people
look this was a hard deal
and there yesterday we honored the
memory and the families
the
John and Pat Hume and David Trimble
I wish they'd lived to this day
Lord knows they took enough licks I they
earned the right to be here
but the good Lord had other plans
they knew both of them knew
that they would suffer politically
for their success
for the reason I said the buyer's remark
would set in people would want
the toughest deal makers they could get
then
and they did it anyway
or
in
Shameless he needs
memorable words they walk on air against
their better judgment
and if they were here today
both of them would say
I'm glad we did that
some things are more important
than the next election
they so
we had popular
opinion demanding piece we had
a good peace process with vigorous able
comprehensive combative leaders
and a great manager in George Mitchell
and we had
organized support
from important areas
there's a lot been made about the
importance of women's groups here
and some of you
including your Chancellor have been on
this for a long time going back to the
time of the peace process
but again there's data that supports
that
we know that Peace Accords
are 35 percent more likely to last at
least 15 years
if women participate in the process
and uh
now
you know I expect Jerry Adams to get
some sort of
International awards for
women's rights as the sinfain is
virtually purged itself of male
leadership
all right
we're laughing about this but it's
important
the young people are important too
they were always
in the right place here most of them
the kids that introduced me at mackie's
plant way back in 1995
down to the students that I meet
in 2023
not only on campus it's walking the
streets just talking to people
and
that's the last point I want to make
one of the real problems with people
like me who used to be something
is that we love talking about
what we did when we were whatever it was
we were as if God we were inspired and
we were tough and we were brave but we
were brilliant we hardly ever made a
mistake and oh if only to people today
were half as good as we were then
everything would be leveling
that's the biggest other ball I've ever
heard in my life
those of us who were there then should
thank God every day that we were lucky
enough to be where we were to have an
opportunity when time and circumstances
permitted to play a small role and a big
lift in The Human Condition
and that means
and
but what that means is that all of us
should endeavor
and I have tried for more than 22 years
now since I left the White House to do
this
I've tried in ways large and small I
never tell War Stories when I give
public speeches unless I have
specifically asked to talk about
something that happened then as if it
were relevant today
otherwise I don't do it I try to live in
the present and for the future and so
should we all
and that's why I'd really enjoyed as
much as anything else in this conference
is listening to all of you who have
Physicians now talking about what we
should do
but I do think
the people that I was privileged to work
with
Bertie and Tony and their
predecessors
I still remember Albert Reynolds
when I asked him I called him I said
they call to give Adams a Visa
he said I do
I said why he said blah blah blah I gave
me the reasons
and uh
I said I'll probably get the hell kick
out of me he said you will
but you should do it
I was lucky
that I had people to talk to from the
beginning
who talked straight and shot straight
what is the future about the future is
about
now that I think the biggest roadblock
to the that brexit pose
for Northern Ireland's political and
economic future has been dramatically
mitigated
is to figure out what the heck answers
practically at issue here not
rhetorically
not ideologically practically an issue
what else
needs to change
to protect that day to day
legitimate pursuit of making a living
and deal with it
but this whole deal was never supposed
to be
an engine
of obstruction
the agreement
was never supposed to be used
to make sure there could be no
self-government
to make sure people should give up on it
and we know what the votes were in the
last election we can add them up their
allocation of seats in the Parliamentary
body and it's time to get the show on
the road
and uh I think
I want to say one other thing that is
purely
selfish
I mean not
for me is a as a citizen
as a father as a grandfather
I am really worried
about how
politics has drifted
away from serious issues
that affect people's daily lives
into identity issues
which are
subject to infinite twisting
and are the main purpose of
them is to convince people
that
some of us are more human than others
some of us are more worthy than others
and that our differences matter more
than our common Humanity
and it's worked out better than I ever
thought it could I'll give it to the
people on the other side they've proved
that if you just keep telling people
long enough
that you know
infidels are at the gate and we're about
to go to hell in a hand basket and all
this stuff that goes on in the United
States and lots of other places in the
world it's worked better than I thought
it would
but there is a half-life to it and
people do get sick of it
and the basic decent Humanity you see
and almost everybody person to person
eventually reasserts itself
the most
lyrical description of it I've seen in
modern literature
is the end of Isabella wilkerson's great
book cast
where she's a widow and one of her two
children has just died she's been
through hell
and her husband when he was ill and knew
he wasn't going to live long had
meticulously written out
instructions for practical things
who do you call if the plumbing fails
so the water was Dripping in her
basement and she looked at her husband's
notes and she called the person
and the guy shows up
and for those who don't know her she's a
distinguished black academic
at Princeton who's written a lot of
wonderful books and Cass compares
the caste system in India with the race
situation in America
but it's really about Modern Life
so anyway
but the end of this very serious book is
about her trying to get the water leak
fixed in her basement
and the guy that shows up to fix a leak
it's got a
Maga cap on
one of the Trump make America great
again hats and he looks at her this very
refined elegant black woman and said
where's the lady of the house
and she says that would be me
she explains what happened he goes down
there's water everywhere
he says well we've got to move these
boxes and at first he makes no attempt
to help her
and then he says
I think this is not a water leak I think
something happened to your air
conditioning
and we can't fix that
and you know it's all it's tending
toward disaster
and then
because looking at all these boxes in
the basement a lot of you have boxes in
the basement don't you that's
and he sees these old pictures
some of them very old he said are these
your family photos
and she she said yes
he said you know you've got to do
something about these these are
beautiful pictures and
and they could get ruined and he starts
helping her move everything
away from the leak
and then he says
I want to give you somebody you can call
about this air conditioning thing the
guy's very honest and won't cheat you
he'll give you good prices and then the
next morning he comes back
to her house to make sure that she got
the guy and he's going to fix and all of
a sudden he's dealing with this woman
who had once symbolized something he
thought he had to rail against as if she
were a real life human being
in other words he's doing what all of
you did 25 years ago when you started
this
living as a Lea life human being
when I was a little boy my mother told
me one day
I came home Furious
and some Thug had
done something at school I thought was
terrible
you said Billy try to make you mad
didn't he
I said he did he said he did make you
mad didn't he I said yes she said
anybody whose only goal is to make you
mad is not your friend
you can never stop thinking
you can never stop feeling
so look I
I know what I would do I think if I had
some job
in the British government or the Irish
government or
the Northern Ireland political system
tomorrow
but that's not nearly as important
is you doing it
guys like me need to get out of town I
mean they they're already doing what
they so often do trying to spew
resentment against us for showing up in
the first place
which I think is funny because I think
showing up in the first place helped you
get to where we are now
but uh the
uh
do you still have problems sure
there we need more economic growth we
need less inequality you need you've got
some health issues you need to resolve
and you've got to have a functioning
government to do all that and there are
these other things out there but
I think that's what
the British government wants I think
it's what the Irish government wants and
I know it's what the people outside want
and so
so I thank you
for giving me an unforgettable week
and I thank you for caring about all
this
and I ask you not to be discouraged this
is human Affairs there are very few
permanent victories or defeats in human
Affairs all these old ugly problems are
always rearing their heads
and you just have to suck it up and beat
it back
and deal with it
you'll be fine
if you remember
what got you here
you are no longer Walking on Air against
your better judgment
if samosini were still alive and he were
here
he would say we walked on air against
our better judgment
now you have a hard floor to walk on for
God's sakes get up and walk
so
this whole thing has been one of the
great blessings of my life
and I can't wait to see what you do with
it
God bless you thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone secretary
Clinton President Clinton a very hard
act to follow
um
president Wonderland another very hard
act to follow and uh president Michelle
University president in Greer and
honored guests first of all my thanks to
everyone here in Queens for what has
been a wonderful conference uh host over
the past three days I've had the
opportunity to follow it from Dublin to
catch it on the news every evening and
it's been really worthwhile so thank you
so much to all the organizers for making
this happen
reflective diverse engaging and
challenging everything that we'd expect
from a university that has produced some
of the finest tankers leaders and Poets
on these islands to enter the centuries
[Applause]
The Good Friday agreement concluded 25
years ago challenged our assumptions of
what we once thought possible
it gave us a pathway to a better future
and I know from reading back on the
history and watching all the
documentaries that we've seen on our
televisions in recent weeks that even in
the weeks and days leading up to April
10th many believed that it wouldn't be
possible to reach an agreement which all
sides could live with
the difficult compromise is required
were seen as political impossibilities
for many of those involved and observing
but Vision leadership and optimism
triumphed in the end
leaders defied assumptions about what
was possible
and they also defied those in their own
communities and in some cases their own
parties who would have preferred to stay
mired in Conflict than avoid having to
make concessions our compromises
they realize that to see their way to a
better future they have to reject the
divisions and differences that had kept
Northern Ireland in what seemed like an
unresolvable impasse for many decades
I know these cannot have been easy
decisions to make
and some paid a very high personal or
political price
I know that earlier in this conference
there was much reflection on the
contribution made by the leaders of 1998
including those who've sadly lost in the
time since
they were the architects
of that better future on behalf of all
of us and I pay tribute to them for what
they've achieved
and as somebody who was I think 18 or 19
years old when the Good Friday agreement
was signed I've had the privilege of
living most of my life In the period
since the Good Friday agreement and on
behalf of my generation I want to thank
those leaders as Architects from the
bottom of my heart
because
I know without the courage and vision
of those leaders from right across
political traditions on these islands
the last 25 years would have been very
different we certainly would not be
marking 25 years of Peace here today
we would not have had the prosperity or
the investment on the scale that we've
experienced either North or South of the
Border
I don't think we would have reversed
that tide of emigration that went on for
Generations on our Island North and
South and I definitely do not think we
would have made the kind of social
progress that we made in Ireland in the
last couple of decades
I think few could have imagined the
degree to which the Good Friday
agreement would transform relationships
at every level across these islands
as we Face new challenges we should not
lose sight of this
The Architects of the agreement
understood the importance of looking
towards the future
and speaking on the receipt of his Nobel
Prize
David Trimble said and I quote
there are Hills in Northern Ireland and
there are mountains
the dark shadow we seem to see in the
distance is not really a mountain ahead
but the shadow of the mountain behind a
shadow from the past thrown forward into
our future
we can leave it behind us if we wish
and I think in saying that Lord Trimble
challenged us all
he challenged us to look forward to the
future and challenge us to make the act
of choices required to help us to avoid
the mistakes of the past
and the agreement created a space in
which people could articulate and work
for the future that they wish to see
it recognizes that we don't need to have
the same aspirations in order to
cooperate and work together
if the agreement achieved a delegate but
vitally important balance on totemic
issues
strengthened by core principles
including those of consent and parity of
esteem
it recognized the need to Encompass the
totality of relationships those within
Northern Ireland
north south and between Britain and
Ireland and whatever may change in the
next few years or decades I don't think
that will change we'll still have to
make sure we get it right in terms of
those three crucial relationships
it also recognized
that people could be British or Irish or
both and be accepted as such and I think
that was crucial and there is an
increasingly growing middle ground in
Northern Ireland willing to do so and I
believe that will be significant into
the future
the principle of consent is vital to the
agreement success
for nationalists that lays out a
democratic pathway by which a United
Ireland can be achieved
for unionists it recognizes that
Northern Ireland is an integral part of
the United Kingdom and Will Remain the
case unless and until the majority of
people in Northern Ireland want that to
change and indeed a majority in the
South too
in recognition of these delicate
balances in the Republic we went
directly to the people with a referendum
to change our constitution to take
account of that principle of consent
with over 90 percent of people voting
yes in the Republic and over 70 percent
of people voting yes here in the North
we had clear Democratic consent for an
agreed Wade forward on the island
perhaps for the first time in centuries
and here in Belfast today I want to
rededicate the Irish government
to continue to work with all of the
parties in Northern Ireland and with our
partners in London to drive the process
forward to the benefits of everyone on
our Islands
and so both governments have an ongoing
obligation to honor and implement the
agreement and that's why I'm so pleased
to be here with prime minister sunac
today having a meeting later on here in
Belfast
the peace process I believe has always
been at its strongest when the two
governments have worked hand in hand
and Northern Ireland works best when the
two governments work together with an
agreed strategy
a partnership approach often based on
difficult decisions has been has been
decisive in driving things forward at
crucial points in the past
the 1985 angle Irish agreement signed by
Margaret Thatcher and Gary Fitzgerald
the dining Street declaration agreed by
Albert Reynolds and John major and the
Good Friday agreement itself and all the
Milestones that had followed were only
possible because of the joint approach
from the two governments
and to quote the prime minister
the agreement was born of partnership
together
and I believe we can make the Good
Friday agreement fulfill its promise for
reconciliation and shared achievement
colleagues I'm particularly delighted
that so many of our International
friends are here with us today
while the agreement belongs first and
foremost to the people of Britain and
Ireland it was built with the help of
our partners from around the world
and we're so grateful that so many
people
in other parts of the world have an
ongoing deep and meaningful interest in
what happens in Ireland
it's impossible to list all of the
individuals that made their mark on our
peace process and I'm not going to try
to do so
but if you just think of some of the
countries that have made a contribution
the United States South Africa Finland
Canada and indeed the countries of the
European Union just hearing that list
evokes a roll call of individuals to
hope to whom we owe our deep
appreciation
so I'm grateful to all of you
those with us and those who travel the
Journey of peace with us for your
support over the decades
it's not simply a matter of History
you've heard directly from president
vonderlein and president Michelle
earlier of their ongoing commitments to
the Good Friday Belfast agreement and to
Northern Ireland
and last week President Biden spoke
powerfully in this place of his and the
United States ongoing commitment to
peace and Reconciliation on this island
and for that we are truly grateful
and I know special Envoy Kennedy's
presence here with us today and indeed
for many days
is further concrete proof of this a
reminder of the opportunities that lie
ahead
if we reach together
the peace process has given us the
opportunity to unlock these
possibilities and to unlock new
opportunities and new prosperity
and because of the peace and stability
brought about by the agreement now parts
of all of our futures are being built
here in Northern Ireland
companies from around the world have
come to Northern Ireland creating jobs
and prosperity
indigenous Enterprise has flourished and
I believe that there is much better yet
to come
a prosperous Northern Ireland benefits
us all
the all Island economy has so much
potential to drive growth to the
advantage of everyone in Britain and
Ireland
and I believe that the Irish governments
shared Island initiative can play an
even greater role investing in the
future of this island and here in the
North
resolving issues that matter to people
the most and finding better ways to work
together and understand one another and
this is something I'm very serious about
so we'll continue to engage with all
communities and traditions on the island
to build a vision for our shared future
in inclusive constructive approach
underpinned by the principles of the
agreement
we firmly hope that the Windsor
framework will play an essential role in
securing additional investment in
Northern Ireland as well as offering
real economic benefits to communities
across Northern Ireland
the framework has been welcomed by the
business Community which has expressed a
desire to move forward and take
advantage of the opportunities and the
certainty that it offers
at prosperous Northern Ireland is a
place where people will want to live in
but want to make work
a place where young people will stay and
return to
it's interesting to know that
increasingly we see people from all
parts of the world choosing to live here
in Northern Ireland
the last census tells us that a hundred
and twenty four thousand people now
living in the north were not born in
either Ireland or Britain that's
extraordinary and it's a positive and
interesting thing in my view
it's also a testament to how far we've
come that so many people from other
parts of Europe and indeed from Beyond
Europe have chosen to make Northern
Ireland their home
the continued Prosperity requires a
functioning government
and public services need to be reformed
improved and invested in
and that's why I believe the people of
Northern Ireland deserve a functioning
executive assembly and north south
ministerial Council and we'll work
thank you
and so the challenges of today require
Northern Ireland's leaders to make the
decisions that affect
the communities on the ground
in conclusion I believe that the Good
Friday agreement above all was about
defying historical expectations
and we need that kind of leadership
still
speaking after the agreement was
concluded
John Hume said and I quote
Eunice and nationalists have at last
taken the future in their hands
They seized control of their history
rather letting history hold them in
thrall
its incumbent on Northern Ireland's
political leaders today to take the
initiative
to see past the shadow of the Mansion
behind
to seize control of their history to
seize control of their of their Destiny
and to lead people into a better future
and we as co-guaranteers of the
agreement will be here to help every
step of the way thank you very much
together
[Music]
your story's Gonna Change just wait for
a better days
just wait for Better Days
please welcome to the stage the prime
minister of the United Kingdom the right
honorable Rishi sunak
[Applause]
good afternoon
the Belfast Good Friday agreement will
always be remembered as one of the most
extraordinary political achievements of
our lifetimes
because step by step
faltering at first people on all sides
began to do things that were once
Unthinkable in the search for peace
but you don't need me to tell you that
because many of you in this room created
it
it's humbling to be with you today
and with the people of Northern Ireland
who have endured so much
after three long decades where violence
and Terror were part of everyday life
a generation has grown up in a place
that is vastly more peaceful more
prosperous and more at ease with itself
now of course we meet here today in
circumstances that are far from perfect
but my argument today is this
the Belfast Good Friday agreement
Remains the best and only foundation for
peace and prosperity
and if we can take inspiration and
instruction from the way peace was
achieved 25 years ago
we can fulfill the true promise
enshrined in that agreement
the promise of stable devolved
government a prosperous economy and a
more united Society
that's the future for Northern Ireland
we must build
now to do that we must first ask why
why did peace talk succeed in 1998 when
so many had failed before
now I believe that's because people on
all sides showed courage imagination and
perseverance
first those who worked for peace had the
personal courage to keep going in spite
of daily threats to them and their
families and the political courage to
take risks in pursuit of a higher goal
John Hume over his entire career never
relented in his insistence on
non-violence
David Trimble took enormous risk to do
what he thought was right for the union
and they were rightly honored as the
preeminent architects of peace with a
joint Nobel Peace Prize
Jerry Adams and Martin McGinnis
persuaded Republicans to join a
constitutional power sharing assembly
and encouraged by the Intensive efforts
of momolam the leaders of loyalism also
lent their weight behind the deal
email leaders from the women for peace
and the women's Coalition worked so hard
for peace
and Bertier Hearn showed the wisdom and
statecraft to see the historic
opportunity
at a critical moment he recognized
unionist concerns over the proposed
north-south arrangements and stepped
back
Trimble himself in his last public
appearance at this University just weeks
before he passed away embraced his old
counterpart and thanked Bertie for
giving him the space to act
these acts of courage
were more powerful than a thousand bombs
and bullets
because there is nothing glamorous about
violence there is nothing glorious about
Terror
squalid acts are always Justified with
some false dream about what they will
achieve
but they have never worked and they
never will
[Applause]
instead
let us glorify moderation
romanticize respect and make Heroes of
those with the courage to reject
absolutes not kill for them
now second Making Peace required leaps
of imagination
to conceive of a system for power
sharing between traditions
to design an agreement with three
strands of equal importance to enshrine
the principle of consent so that
Northern Ireland remains a part of the
United Kingdom for as long as its people
wish while protecting the aspirations of
those who seek a different future
through peaceful means
and for the first time
the people of North and South were both
given the opportunity to support the
deal
and they did so in overwhelming
majorities
and let us never forget the crucial work
after 1998 to build a broader consensus
helped by the leadership of Dr Ian
Paisley
and third
the peace took extraordinary
perseverance
in the aftermath of the shankill bomb
and gray steel massacre in 1993 many
thought the peace process was over
but just two months later John Major and
Albert Reynolds delivered the Downing
Street declaration
George Mitchell persuaded all parties to
sign up to the principles of democracy
and non-violence without which the talks
could not have begun
and in the difficult Final hours
President Clinton's timely interventions
helped get the deal done and whenever
people walked away
Tony Blair sought to bring them back
always committed always attuned to the
concerns of all parts of the community
together with bertia Hearn he showed us
what's possible when the UK and Irish
governments work together a partnership
I know will continue alongside my friend
Leo varadka
and in the spirit of perseverance it's
also fitting to recognize the
contribution of the security forces now
like my predecessors
I acknowledge that at times they made
mistakes
but we must also recognize their bravery
suffering and sacrifice and that of the
police
without their courageous service there
would have been no peace process at all
they created the conditions that
ultimately allowed their own presence on
the streets to be reduced or entirely
withdrawn
so courage
imagination and perseverance
those qualities brought an imperfect but
enduring piece to a place taught to
believe no such peace was possible
so to all those who led us to that peace
including those in this Hall and those
no longer with us
let us take this moment to say to all of
you
thank you
[Applause]
now for those of us like me who inherit
this extraordinary even intimidating
Legacy our challenge today
is to fulfill the promise of the work
that you began
to honor your legacy
we need to create a more stable devolved
government in Northern Ireland and that
means getting the institutions up and
running
[Applause]
now I believe there are two tasks first
to remove the biggest block to the
institutions remain returning and that's
why when I came into office I made it a
priority to fix the Northern Ireland
protocol and we were deeply conscious of
the lessons of history as we did so
that's why our aims were to balance and
respect the aspirations of all parts of
the community protect the relationships
between East and West as much as north
and south and persist through careful
detailed negotiation
and I pay tribute to Ursula vondeline
who I'm so pleased to see here today
foreign
The Windsor framework is a breakthrough
moment it solves practical problems and
crucially strengthens Northern Ireland's
place in our Union and our UK internal
Market it gives the assembly significant
new powers ready for when it sits again
and I am confident we can build broad
support for it across all communities
so why share people's frustrations that
the institutions are not back up and
running
but that points to our second task
we must keep working to persuade all
parts of the community that returning to
the institutions is the best path
and we will do that we will talk we will
listen we will try to persuade and we
will not give up
and I want to speak directly for a
moment to the representatives of
unionism who include many diverse voices
and whose concerns with the protocol we
are focused on addressing
I urge you to work with us to get storm
on up and running again that's the right
thing to do in its own terms
and I'm convinced it's also the right
thing to do for our union now I'm a
proud unionist We passionately believe
that Northern Ireland is stronger within
the United Kingdom and the United
Kingdom is stronger with Northern
Ireland within it
but we must also build support Beyond
those of us who already identify as
unionists to do that we have to show
that devolved government within the
United Kingdom works for Northern
Ireland
you know the fact that the institutions
have been down for nine of the last 25
years should be a source of profound
concern
over the long term that will not bolster
the cause of unionism I believe that
deeply
so we need to get the institutions up
and running and keep them up and running
and let me also say to those who would
seek to reform the institutions right
now I understand your frustrations but
history reminds us that nothing in
Northern Ireland has ever been achieved
by trying to get around one Community or
another
so any conversation about reform can
only begin once the institutions are up
and running again and if it attracts
widespread consent
the Belfast Good Friday agreement left
us an extraordinary and precious Legacy
when we look back in 25 years from now
surely we should Aspire for our Legacy
to be nothing less than this that the
institutions have been up and running
for every single year
because our Focus must be on the future
getting the institutions back up and
running is our most pressing challenge
to honor your legacy
but that's only the beginning
together we must fulfill the true
promise of the 1998 agreement
that future enshrined in the very words
of the text of sustained economic growth
and where we tackle the problems of a
divided Society
I will give everything to help deliver
that vision
because I talked earlier about learning
the lessons from history
one thing I took from George Mitchell
is the idea that the agreement itself is
only 20 of the task the rest is delivery
once the agreement was done people asked
if Tony Blair would he walk away
he didn't and neither will I
because
there is work to be done so let me tell
you what I'm going to do first economic
growth
progress has been remarkable in April
1998 Northern Ireland had the highest
unemployment rate in the United Kingdom
today
it's the second lowest
but we need to do more in 25 years when
we look back I want to see that Northern
Ireland has changed
from an economy to relying on the public
sector to a thriving Dynamic economy
built around the power and innovation of
private Enterprise
now I talk a lot about the idea of
leveling up about making sure young
people can feel that they can fulfill
their dreams and aspirations in the
place they call home
that idea has particular resonance here
in Northern Ireland
and we won't achieve it without a
Cascade of new investment to create jobs
and opportunity
now that Journey has already begun last
week President Biden came and told the
world to invest here
now he didn't say that out of
sentimentality he said it because he can
see the opportunity for American
businesses and because of the enormous
potential of this place
the potential of the people resilient
ingenious determined
the potential of your businesses with
world-class strengths in cyber Life
Sciences financial services and the
creative Industries and one of Europe's
Most thriving start-up scenes
I know that journey to Prosperity won't
be easy
and we aren't there yet
but this is my commitment to you
I will use the full force and power of
the UK government to help you make one
of this the best places in the world to
start and grow a business create jobs
train and learn new skills and attract
investment
foreign
and just as we want to look back on a
more prosperous Dynamic economy
so in 25 years
I also want us to look back on a more
integrated and contented Society
of course we cannot simply wish away
those social realities that have been
present for decades
the tragic loss of Lyra McKee and the
attack on DCI John Caldwell remind us
how far we still have to go
but people are already voting with their
feet in the choices they make for their
children's education and in their social
and sporting lives
a growing body of the electorate does
not define themselves solely as unionist
or nationalist British or Irish
a growing portion of people sample life
in different parts of these islands but
still return
and a growing number of local
communities are signaling that their
patients with thuggery is over
but there's yet more to do
in 25 years
should not the poisonous grip of the
palamilitaries those gangsters and drug
dealers who wrap themselves in the fake
cloak of legitimacy be broken once and
for all
in 25 years
should not a fragment of a peaceful be
nothing more than a stop on the tourist
Trail
and in 25 years
should integrated education not be the
norm rather than the exception
of course
we won't build that better future
overnight
and it won't always be easy
every time I visit Northern Ireland
I feel more optimistic and hopeful
because to paraphrase the late David
Trimble
there may be Hills ahead of us but there
are mountains behind
and I want to close by reflecting on an
extraordinary story
just weeks before the agreement
two lifelong friends
Damien trainer and Philip Allen were
murdered at points pass
one was a Protestant
the other Catholic
now the people who murdered them
may have hoped to sow chaos and Division
and derail the peace talks
they failed
because the story of this remarkable
friendship inspired one of the most
decisive breakthroughs of the whole
peace process
the agreement to share power between
equal first and Deputy first ministers
in a co-premership with one from each
community
as Mark Durkin the sdlp's lead
negotiator said at the time
the stories
of Philip and Damien's special
friendship
could be a parable
for the sort of society that we might
create if we could reach agreement
and he was right
that is the promise
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
and together we can
and we must fulfill it thank you